ces résultats vont à l'encontre des
discours des autorités sanitaires
selon une étude publiée par la revue
américaine jama paediatrics les enfants
de moins de cinq ans pourraient être
extrêmement contagieux entre le 23 mars
et le 27 avril
une équipe de chercheurs a mené des
tests de dépistage sur 145 patients
ayant développé une forme légère du coc
vite 19
ils ont été répartis en trois groupes 46
enfants de moins de 5 ans 51 enfants
âgés de 5 à 17 ans et 48 adultes de 18 à
65 ans chez les moins de 5 ans le taux
de matériel génétique du corona des rues
se retrouver dans leur nez et à 10 à 100
fois supérieur à celui présent dans le
nez des enfants plus âgés et des adultes
voici ce qu'on a conclu l'équipe notre
étude se limite à la détection de
l'acide nucléique virale plutôt que
celle du virus infectieux bien que des
études pédiatriques sur le sar skov 2 et
mis en évidence une corrélation entre
les taux d'acides nucléiques plus élevés
et la capacité à cultiver le virus
infectieux les habitudes
comportementales des jeunes enfants
ainsi que les locaux exigus dans les
écoles et les garderies pose la question
d'une propagation du sart skov de dans
cette population
à mesure que les contraintes sanitaires
s'assouplissent si les jeunes enfants
s'avère être plus contagieux que prévu
il ne serait pas non plus invincible
face au virus pour reprendre le mot du
directeur général de l'om est ce le 30
juillet dernier durant une conférence de
presse il s'est inquiété de la baisse de
vigilance des jeunes populations face au
virus
les exhortant à prendre davantage de
précautions nous l'avons dit et nous
leur disons les jeunes peuvent être
infectés les jeunes peuvent mourir et
les jeunes peuvent transmettre le virus
il semble que les résurgences des
nouveaux cas dans certains pays sont en
partie dus à des jeunes qui baissent la
garde pendant l'été dans l'hémisphère
nord
les avis divergent sur la façon dont les
jeunes sont touchés par le cos vite 19
et leur potentiel contagiosité
une récente étude en ile-de-france en
date du 4 juin dernier par exemple
démontré que je cite les enfants
semblaient être moins contaminés et
moins contaminant au début de la crise
on a cru comme pour d'autres virus
respiratoires que les enfants jouent un
rôle important dans la propagation
l'idée me ce n'est pas le cas les
évidences s'accumulent
cette maladie touche essentiellement les
adultes les formes les plus graves et
les décès survenant quasi exclusivement
chez des sujets âgés ou présentant des
comorbidités difficile donc de s'y
retrouver face à toutes ses études aux
résultats contradictoires
un peu comme pour le port du masque les
autorités sanitaires peine à parler
d'une seule voix